Allahbar. Allahbar.
[Silence]
Shal.
Longe
[Silence]
Oh, no.
Oh,
[Silence]
Honest.
Beautiful. Allah
in
long.
Alhamdulillah. Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
say
Quran was
[Silence]
My dear brothers, respected elders,
beloved youth, mothers and sisters, we
thank Allah subhanaa tala for keeping us
alive on the path of the and allowing me
and you to enter his house and worship
him in the manner that pleases him. I
ask Allahh accept from me and accept
from you the little we do in his path.
And I bear witness there's no deity
worthy of worship except for Allah
subhanaa tala and prophet Muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam is his last
and final messenger. For surely he will
Allah subhanaa tala choose to guide
which can misguide and he would choose
to misguide us and guide guide him back
to the path and we seek refuge in Allah
from darkness of ourselves and evil of
had for Allah is all knowing and all
seeing what his creation does. So
today's I want to focus on something
that might not
be you know seemingly something that we
don't pay attention to or we don't focus
on and it might be connected and it
might not be connected depending upon
your perception of the life that is
currently going on or the life we
live. there was a time
when in this country you would never had
a problem expressing your faith or views
because those things are given as a
right on this land. But as we live today
increasingly you see the faith of
Muslims being tested every single day in
a different manner.
And part of that is that we need to
remember that Allah subhana
ta did not put us in this situation or
in this land because he thought we were
too smart. We were too good-looking. We
were too savvy. We had all the right
answers. We were too
educated and we were too learned.
Allah subhana ta looked at the souls of
all the people all the souls he created
in the
heavens and the first thing Allah
subhanaa t asked when he pulled every
single soul out of
Adam he asked him as Quran captures
it he asked each one of us am I not your
lord and we all agreed to it and the
second thing we agreed to was what Allah
mentions in the Quran that when Allah
subhanaa tala chose to bring his
revelation his Quran
thean the haya
the every single creation of Allah said
we are not
capable even Allahh goes as far as
mentioning the strongest thing on the
earth the mountains
Even the mountain said we would not bear
it. If it was put upon us, we will
crumble into dust. But it was us, the
son of Adam, the bunny
Adam, that chose to have that covenant
given to us by Allah subhana wa ta'ala.
We willingly took it. And as such,
Allahh captures that in the Quran for us
beautifully.
Adam, he said, "I've honored the
children of Adam because we chose a
difficult path that laid ahead of
us
knowingly." Now, you could come to me
and say, "Heck, well, you know, I don't
remember when I was in Jenna. I don't
remember, you know, as my as my my
5-year-old now, mashallah, reminds me,
, I came home one day and my wife
said you would need to listen to him
what he says." And I said, "What did he
say?" He said, "You know, Baba, you
chose me when I was in Jenna." I said,
"Alhamdulillah, I did. I did choose you
as you were in Jenna." So, we all were
chosen and you did not come to this
country because a mistake or a
fluke or you had a better skill set than
the next
person. Allah chose you to be here
because there's a job for us to do.
Now you can willingly do the job or you
can willingly not do that job.
Regardless, Allah will do the job and he
will have somebody who will do the job
for us. So either we choose to become a
tool in the belt of or the toolbox of
Allah subhana wa ta'ala or we choose not
to be one. That is our choice. That is
the free will that Allah has given us.
So regardless of how difficult the
things
are, we have a job to do and we'll
continue doing
it. As Allah subh reminds us that
whoever fixates on the worldly
gains, for the person who fixates on the
worldly gains, he has a livelihood that
is not beneficial to him in any way.
But it's something that keeps him
grinding further and further as we say
in English in a rabbit hole. He keeps
going down the rabbit hole further and
further and further and
further. And as the saying is mentioned
is that a person
whose whose worry is Allah put writes
down he puts right here for him. What is
Look up the word. What does it
mean? Mashallah, you all are here. Mah,
either Arabic speakers or you're from
Pakistan, India. What a fak means in
Pakistan Indian language. What does it
mean? It literally is a beggar who's
begging the whole time.
as
Allah as Allah captures it so
beautifully in the Quran such eloquence
in that one
ayah and those who came to the believers
and said surely men have
gathered against
you so be fearful ful of these people.
Become subservant to them. Fear them
because if you don't do what they ask
you to do, your livelihood will be taken
away. Your jobs will be taken away. Your
status will be taken away. Your house
will be taken
away. Your life will be upside
down. So what does he say? What does
Allahh say? What happens to these
people?
their im goes up
more. They say Allah is sufficient for
us and he's the excellent and he's the
most excellent
protector. And that's the truth. That's
the truth of what iman needs to be. But
unfortunately, our ims are weak today.
Our ims have become super weak because
we have associated things that are not
part of the iman.
was famous for no saying to his
companions to his friends
to he used to say
come come on so that we increase our
iman and he cometh to us sit with us and
we can increase our iman. How do we
increase our iman?
First and foremost, part of increasing
iman is understanding what iman
is. From
immif and some of the other theologians,
you know, the the tongue has to say it.
It's for them. It's a of im your tongue
has to utter the kima out
of show me an oath. any oath in the
world when you pledge your
allegiance that starts with
no. There isn't
one. On the face of the earth, there's
not a pledge that starts with
no. Except for the allegiance of Allah
[Arabic recitation]
tala. Most of you went to schools here.
If not, your kids are in school. What is
your pledge of allegiance?
I
pledge or you take an oath. You say
I so and so take an oath
hereby. You never start by saying no I
don't. Oh, I don't pledge the
allegiance. No, you say I
do. Even when you get married, you say I
do. That's the biggest allegiance.
Subhan Allah. Cuz you know if you didn't
place pledge that one has to be
I'm
but your allegiance starts with no to
Allahh. No there is no God worthy of
worship except for Allah subhana
tala. No
god. And then it
continues because the needs to be there
that no has to strike hard and
understanding for you and myself is that
there's nothing nothing in this
world that is worthy of it.
Nothing. Point blank period.
Nothing. You might think or we might it
might seem that my risk is
connected to this and your risk is
connected to that. Allah has decreed
your risk in some excuse me
durations 10,000 years before we were
born in some 40,000 years before we were
born 40,000 or 10,000 years regardless.
Take the lesser number 10,000 years
before I was
born. What did the earth look like
10,000 years ago?
Do we have these? No. Do we have all
these beautiful modern cars?
No. Do we have central air air
conditioners?
No. I was talking to a brother, you
know, the other day and you know, he was
mentioning a story, but part of the
story was there was a on the house they
live there was an evap cooler and he
reminded me older houses in Tucson had
evap coolers. They didn't even have any
central ACs.
So 10,000 years before and I and you
were born, Allah had decreed a risk for
us, our sustenance for us. And by the
way, risk is just not the food that we
eat. That's the most common
misconception that we have of
risk. Risk is every single thing that
Allah blesses you with.
your child, your
children, your house, your job, your
isah, your
respect, every single thing, your
wife, those are all part of your
risk that's included in your
risk and that's from Allah subhana tala.
But we commonly associate it such
narrowly to one part and that is just
the food or the money that comes into my
house. So the or
the used to have this habit of sitting
together and discussing and worshiping
Allahh in a combined manner.
So there is their their iman goes
up. And by the way, this is this is just
a common thing to keep in mind. Even in
the time of
Sahaba, the iman goes up and down.
There's levels of iman. Eman changes on
a daily
basis. On a daily basis, it goes up, it
goes down, it goes up, it goes down.
But having that with Allah subhana
tala having that belief in Allah subhana
tala that if things are bad today they
will be
better what would be known
as Allahh mentions
in I am what my servant thinks of
And asam mentioned in the
And that's from of Allahh. If he loves a
nation, he puts them into
trials. Now you tell me who's the best
nation. Tell me, are we suffering or
just another nation that's suffering
greater than us right
now? So meaning what?
They are the chosen people of Allahh.
Allah has chosen chosen them
specifically for this
task and part of us should be
jealous. What have they done to deserve
that mercy of Allah subhana tala? Look,
I remind you you might be confused
because I'm going remind you here for a
second is suffering. He's in the throws
of death.
The poison that was given to him is
cutting up his
stomach. He's literally in pain,
excruciating
pain and temperature that a normal man
would not have.
We know this from theam that was when
they are given when Allahh flicks them
with with with with a temperature with
fever that's three times as much as a
normal man can
suffer because Allah has chosen
his for specific
tasks. So he's suffering three times
what a common man is
suffering and his daughter is
crying by his bed and he looks at looks
at her and he says after today your
father has no karab all the karab will
be wiped
away all the stresses of the world are
here until we are breathing and beating
our hearts that's it the minute our eyes
close everything goes
away. It's done. Did I pay that bill?
Was that bill due? The car payment went,
the house payment went. That's
everything goes away. What the boss
wanted, the job wanted, the project
wanted, everything is
gone. And some of the most valuable
things to us in this life related to our
jobs, our
economy, they don't even miss a beat
when we're gone. The life continues
smoothly. As they are saying, you know,
graveyards are full of people that they
that that thought the world would not
run without
them. And the world is running without
them and sometimes greater than when
they were
alive. Our iman needs to be in focus. We
need to bring our tongues back first and
foremost of the
But then the second part is that it has
to penetrate in your heart. And this is
not my words. This is what have said in
the books. It has to go into your heart.
The heart has to believe in it. And the
belief is shown through your from your
hands and your feet and your body. How
you act upon the the the Allah subhana
tala.
But that's all in sync of what I'm
mentioning. But let me go back to finish
the hadith real quick. I apologize. I
didn't get to finish the
hadith. And Allahh says for for whoever
goes through the calamity on the nation
and he becomes accepting of that meaning
he has sarah on it and he accept it as a
will of Allah subhana tala then it's
ease for them. And if not they think
it's Allah is punishing me then Allah
says it's a form of punishment for them.
We ask Allahh make us from the former
not the
latter. If you
remember over a year
ago I was still here talking about what
we need to do as Muslims.
And I still remind you today, even
today, we don't have enough
organizations built to take care of our
needs as
communities. If you think we have enough
massages, you're wrong. We need
more. If you think we have enough
nonprofits doing work, you're wrong. We
need more.
I gave a simple example and this is over
a year
ago, more than a year ago, a simple
example that local there is a need for
it and we still don't have any blueprint
for
it. We need a housing shelter that is
equipped to handle
sisters. We need a better and abuse
shelter that is equipped for sisters.
Allah subhana ta is not going to
sendatam down here to help us solve our
issues. We as a community have to come
up with our own
solutions and that only is possible when
Muslims have a broader vision not a
narrower vision in their life.
You see the era that we all cling to and
we claim that was the most golden era
and the most beautiful era is the era of
alandulucia the span the Spaniards that
when we were in Spain and we're ruling
the Portugal and the Spain and we were
so high and mighty at that time a
scholar was just not a scholar of the
Quran or the Hadith.
They were
astronomers. They were
chemists. They were developing lenses.
They were developing other substances.
They were not limited to one
field. We as Muslims today have limited
ourselves. We choose one field and we
get stuck on
it. Wah. I encourage you. I have I have
said this in
a and I said it in
these are my two hands. I beg you stop
making your kids only
doctors. I beg you for Allah's sake. If
you want this ummah to prosper,
stop. We are writing our own death
warrants.
Your doctor kid is not going to come
bail you out from an ICE detention
facility. Your doctor kid is never going
to
be FBI's top
cop. Go look it up. Who's running FBI
today? Look up who's running the
national security team. Who are these
folks? Why is there not a Muslim
representation in
there? Even give us a Muslim that's a
Muslim by name. We'll accept it
inshallah.
We don't even have
that. And then we
cry. Brother, things are bad. Brother,
we made them bad for
ourselves. We have made it bad for
ourselves because we have come to
conform to societal norms around
us. Your family doesn't accept that your
kid is not a doctor. Be
it. They don't have to live his life. He
has to live his own life.
Would you rather have a kid who's happy
and living a life that's fulfilling or
would you rather have a kid that's
miserable for the rest of his life and
cursing for putting him where he wants
to be? He didn't want to be. We ask
Allahh to make us the
people. We ask Allahha that he makes our
affairs easier for us. We ask
Allahh that he blesses us with a vision
that
is beneficial to the community overall
and the ummah overall. We ask Allahh to
make us bright lights just a
lighthouse in the darkness of the storm
so we can guide people to the safety and
the shore. We ask Allahh to protect this
community first and foremost in every
single community around the world. We
ask Allahh to have special mercy on our
brothers and sisters who are suffering
endlessly in Falstina and in Sudan and
in Burma and in China and in Kashmir and
in India. We ask Allahh to give them
relief and provide them from the aid
that we do not know about.
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah. Alhamdulillah.
So we have just a little bit time left
inshallah I'm not going to go into the
whole hadith
ofam but wasam mentioned in authentic
narration a time will come when holding
on to your iman will be holding on
to hot coals and if that's not the
current time I don't know when that is
but I encourage myself and you to be
steadfast on the ama that Allahh has g
given
us we have to do due dill diligence in
what Allah has given to us. I remind you
again, it is not a fluke or a mistake
that he created us Muslims and then he
chose to put us in this land in this
time in this era. None of that is a
mistake from Allah.
His he knows every single thing. He
knows in the darkness of the
night in the dead of the night on the
black rock the black end that crawls. He
knows about that camp moving. So we are
what are we compared to that? He knows
every single thing. He knows our hidden
secrets and what we have in open. So I
encourage myself and you to be steadfast
on
the we ask Allah subhana t to make our
iman as firm as the im
of under the stress and the torment of
the tyrant. He still kept
saying and I remind you
that when he came to Medina and Sahabah
asked him one day yabilad why do you
used to say that word and he said that's
the only word I knew and I knew that it
erased the alhamdulillah we know more
words than that we know the kala better
than that we know the Quran better than
that we know a lot of things so
inshallah we need to become a shining
example and guide the Allah
[Silence]
foreign.
forham. forbill.
[Silence]
Mother to
Allah. Straighten your lines. Close the
gaps in between.
[Silence]
Allah. Alhamdulillah.
canal.
[Silence]
Amen.
Victory.
for fantasy.
[Silence]
for Allah.
Oh, may
Allah Allah
[Silence]
Allah,
Allah, Allah.
Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
Amen.
Yeah.
15.
[Silence]
for
Fore! Foreign!
Foreign!
[Silence]
Fore! Foreign!
Foreign!
[Silence]
for me.
Allah Allah Oh,
[Silence]
Allah.
My dear, Brothers and sisters, asalamu
alaykum. A few announcements I would
to share with you. First, the
theatulama is at 5:15 a.m. starting
tomorrow, inshallah. So, it's 5:15. The
board will be changed and Isha will be
at 8:30 inshallah. So, that again this
board will be updated this afternoon.
there's a halaka tonight for the kids,
for the older boys, younger boys and for
the you know the for the girls also. So
please make use of these halakas.
There's a reason for that and again we
want to make sure we reach to the
children and create that dialogue and
help them learn the dean. Inshallah
Rahma Academy the enrollment is open for
the next calendar year. Please consider
the Rahama Academy as a very viable tool
to educate your children about
Islam. We have a Rahama Academy is up to
the fourth grade now and please make
sure you discuss that with your family,
friends and see what you can do to help
us fill the classes as soon as possible.
the Rama Academy donations that you
provide every year, you provide the
special tax diversion from Arizona state
taxes to the Rahama Academy rather than
paying to the state of Arizona that for
the application of that for the year
2024 that will end in 3 days. So if you
intend to use that credit for 2024 taxes
filing, then that needs to be done very
soon. But you can continue doing that.
This is again for the next year. Any
donation you do will be for 2025 direct
deduction. So again please make sure you
we share that with the brothers and
sisters.